so what went into the decision of when
you were going to do it did you say to
him like let's just do it he asked you
okay so what what happened I haven't
said that yet we I was hanging out like
I was staying in LA at a house near
Jennifer Lawrence who lives right by
Adele and they're really good friends
and I never met her before
so we like hung out a little bit that
week and then we were just real drunk
one night and and you know Chris but we
were talking about how we wanted to get
married and Adele was like well I can
marry you
what if I tried to do her accent well I
can marry get like spot on I'm a dialect
coach uh and we were like okay cool and
she was like and we were making a whole
plan we're like Tuesday at noon because
she you know she like takes care of her
own kid and whatever and then and then
like you know the next day she's like
hey we're not really like friends and I
think she got ordained to marry her good
friends like she was like they'll be
kind of annoyed if I just start marrying
random basic [ __ ]
oh no so she backed out yeah it was like
a night it was like the next day you
know I was like a drunk it was late yeah
yeah and then we like you know we're not
like we're not like yeah she's like I do
not want you to have my phone number
right right hello from the other side I
did not oh I actually did get her number
but I shouldn't I shouldn't never use
them I'm putting it in my phone as do
not you know you should write hello
lol so then we were like should we still
get married on Tuesday and we were like
yeah let's just who cares let's do it so
there's no drama like no planning it
just seems like it you know when you see
your friend go through planning a
wedding it just seems like it's such
yeah yeah everyone thought people
everyone felt like she's pregnant and
you addressed that pretty fast I know
people always just think I'm pregnant
blame that think that's just my friend
for life
so Adele said that she would marry and
then when she backed out you were like
[ __ ] it let's just do it anyway
yeah and that was the invitation process
was just odd text before I text people
yeah yeah there was no we actually never
even made like a cute
it'll like flyer yeah like a text like
we cordially invite no nothing I got
that straight everybody got attacked